[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON: So
hello to friends in the room,
friends who I know are
joining us virtually.
I'm really excited
that you are here.
And thank you,
Justin, for having me.
It's great to be here.
This is part of a big bunch
of research that I started,
some way or another, 13 years
ago, in some way or another,
in 1996, even.
And I want to start by making
the claim that architecture,
AI, and design
are all connected.
These connections go
back some 60 or 70 years,
to 1956 or even 1948.
And newness seems to be
central to how we talk about
artificial intelligence today.
We say things like, AI is the
new black, AI is the new UI.
Artificial intelligence is
the next digital frontier,
according to our
friends at McKinsey.
Andrew Ng stated that AI
is the new electricity.
But also, AI is the
new MOOC, because it
will be an online course
that he's running.
You need data for AI,
so data is the new oil.
The future of computers is the
mind of a disembodied toddler
head.
And apparently, I
am also the new AI,
and I will spare
you what this says,
but it's really, really
sexist and really awful.
If you want to get an
idea of how much the word,
new gets used when
we talk about AI,
you could look at something like
this "MIT Technology Review"
article.
I just highlighted the word,
new where I could find it,
and there were six mentions
in the first two paragraphs.
Of course, I think
one of them was
New York, so I don't think
that that actually counts.
And this gentleman was
a part of a conversation
about tech moguls declaring an
era of artificial intelligence.
But AI isn't the new,
because AI isn't new.
Here's how new it's not.
In 1955, John McCarthy, the
founder of the Stanford AI
Lab, and before
that, the MIT AI Lab,
coined the term
artificial intelligence
to mean making machines do
things that would require
intelligence if done by man.
In 1956, he brought together
a group of researchers
at Dartmouth College
in New Hampshire,
and they spent the
summer hashing out
what they thought the platform
of research on AI should be.
And it included things like
neural nets, and it included--
what does he say.
It says, an attempt
will be made to find
how to make machines
use language,
form abstractions
and concepts, solve
kinds of problems now
reserved for humans,
and improve themselves.
We think that a
significant advance
can be made in one or
more of these problems
if a carefully selected
group of scientists
can work together on
it for a summer, 1956.
Herb Simon, Allen
Newell, and JC Shaw--
Simon and Newell, very important
to Carnegie Mellon's history,
wrote in 1958, that they'd
pretty much figured out
this problem of modeling the
human brain in computing.
They said, "intuition,
insight, and learning
are no longer exclusive
possessions of humans.
Any large scale,
high-speed computer
can be made to
exhibit them, also."
They believed that by the 1960s,
they'd have it figured out.
And of course, Marvin
Minsky, who in 1961 said,
"I believe that we are on
the threshold of an era that
will be strongly influenced,
and quite possibly dominated,
by intelligent
problem-solving machines."
Proto-machine
learning, you might
find in the world of
perceptrons in 1958.
"The New York Times"
published an article
talking about this new Navy
device that learns by doing
and said that,
"the Navy revealed
the embryo of an electronic
computer today that it expects
will be able to walk, talk, see,
write, reproduce itself and be
conscious of its existence.
The Navy said the
perceptron would
be the first non-living
mechanism capable of receiving,
recognizing, and
identifying its surroundings
without any human
training or control."
So all of these
ideas are really old.
They're older than me by
far, and they're older
than a lot of what we work on.
But in addition to this,
I want to point out
that AI and architecture
are old friends
and co-created each other
at a certain point in time,
in ways that has
very direct impacts
on the kind of engineering and
design work that we do today
and the problems
that we focus on.
I'm going to introduce
three of the characters
in my book, "Architectural
Intelligence."
The three people I'm going
to introduce in this talk
are Christopher
Alexander, Cedric Price,
and Nicholas Negroponte.
Who here has heard of
Christopher Alexander?
A couple.
Anyone Cedric Price?
Right on.
And Nicholas Negroponte?
A couple more.
So they're all architects
who worked very closely
with technology in different
kinds of ways, some
so much so that
you don't probably
think of Nicholas Negroponte,
the founder of the MIT Media
Lab, as an architect.
And I'm going to
talk about the ways
that they worked
with cybernetics
and artificial intelligence
to build new kinds of worlds
and new kinds of
approaches in ways
that affect what we do today.
I'll start with
Christopher Alexander.
Christopher Alexander-- if you
do know of his work and even
if you don't-- by me putting
up this book right here,
I've probably begun to bring
him into something you've heard
of before.
He's written many, many books.
He's a mathematician, born
in Vienna, raised in England,
came to the United
States in the 1960s.
He's quite old but still alive,
living in England, again.
He was a professor at Berkeley.
I'll mention three
books today, "Notes
on the Synthesis of Form,"
"A Pattern Language,"
and "The Timeless
Way of Building."
"Notes on the Synthesis
of Form" was his thesis.
And if you've ever
heard the idea of design
being good fit or fitness,
trying to shim a table until it
works, or putting a
stable system in place,
that's where that
idea comes from.
Those of you who've
used patterns--
whether in UX or in software--
are right in the lineage
of Christopher Alexander.
His idea of pattern languages
have influenced this and then
his philosophy of design, which
he outlined in "The Timeless
Way of Building."
If you've ever used a wiki
or used Agile processes,
you have used something
that he's done.
My own research with
Alexander started
when I was reading "Notes
on the Synthesis of Form,"
and this question of AI came up,
when I realized, in a footnote,
he was referring to
Claude Shannon, John
McCarthy, and Marvin Minsky.
And I wondered, why
is this architect--
what does he have to say
about artificial intelligence
in 1964?
13 years later, I have
a book about that.
He was interested
in finding ways
to break down design problems,
so they could be easily
understood and designed.
Anybody who has created
tree diagrams in order
to explain the function of a
piece of software or website
is working in this lineage.
In fact, this is the outputs
of one of his programs.
This is something that's in
the Berkeley archives that
shows how you'd break down the
elements of a design problem
for how you design highways.
He also applied these ideas
to the BART system in 1964.
This is 390 requirements that he
and his team outlined, and this
was before BART was built.
I'm not sure how many of these
are in place today.
I think we probably
need new requirements.
My ears are still ringing
from the BART ride
I took this morning.
"Pattern Language" and
"Timeless Way of Building,"
I already mentioned
briefly, but I
want to tell you a little
bit more about them.
"The Pattern Language,"
as he puts it--
and it's not the only,
it's a pattern language.
It's 253 patterns from
large to small scale.
And then the "Timeless
Way of Building"
is a philosophy of patterns.
And these patterns
are anything from how
to make a nation state, down to
how to organize your bedroom.
And as he and his
collaborators write,
"Each pattern
describes a problem
which occurs over and over
again in our environment,
and then describes the core of
the solution to that problem,
in such a way that you can use
this solution a million times
over, without ever doing
it the same way twice."
So in the book, here's
an example of a pattern.
I live in Pittsburgh, and
I live in a row house.
And so it's very
dense where I live,
and these are patterns about
the design of a row house.
You see, a number, a
statement, a picture--
a statement about
the design problem,
illustrations to carry out--
to explain some of what that
design problem is doing--
and then a connection to
other patterns in the system.
And it works like
an operating system.
The patterns are a network.
So you see, here are a number
of them in their order,
explaining what each of them do.
This is going from a mosaic of
subcultures, all the way down
to a household mix, and it
goes further and further
into more detail.
Alexander is someone that a
lot of technologists have read.
If you know Allen Cooper,
the interaction designer,
he use to ferret out
Christopher Alexander's
books in his high school
library and read them there.
He wanted to be an
architect, so did Kent Beck
and then realized, he didn't
want to build buildings.
He wanted to build
software, and there
was a lot more that you
could do within that world.
And Ward Cunningham
and Kent Beck
were curious about
how they could
apply this idea of
patterns to the idea
of object-oriented
programming languages,
so they applied it to
interface patterns in Smalltalk
in the late '80s and about 1987.
And a community of programmers
got together and over
the years, built up what was
called the design patterns
movement.
And this group of four
men, who called themselves
the gang of four,
are the ones who
created this network of
design patterns in software.
And it's an idea that you see
millions and millions of times.
I think they're something
like $1,200 on Amazon
that refer to design patterns
in software and in interfaces
and games.
Now, how many people have
heard of design patterns?
There you go.
Also, if you've ever used
Agile processes or followed
extreme programming, Kent
Beck and Ward Cunningham
and a number of other
people applied these ideas
about the philosophy of design
from Christopher Alexander
and "The Timeless
Way of Building,"
to up end and change the
politics of the design process
and to give more flexibility
to users and to people.
And when I
interviewed Kent Beck,
he told me that it
was "a rearrangement
of the political power in the
design and building process."
Everyone here has used a
wiki, and the wiki format
was developed by
Ward Cunningham.
He was developing it in
HyperCard in the early '90s,
and then it was suggested
that he could maybe
build this on this new thing
called the World Wide Web.
And what he wanted to do
was have a conversation
that never had an end.
If he wanted to map all of the
knowledge that he and his team
had, he didn't want
to say, it ends here.
He wanted it to be able
to go and go and go.
He never patented
the wiki format,
and it was picked up in the
early 2000s to run Wikipedia.
And now, we've all used
wikis one way or another.
But this is, again,
a direct inspiration
or a direct influenced by
Christopher Alexander project.
So that's Christopher Alexander.
The other thing to say about him
is architects tend to hate him,
and technologists
tend to love him.
I'm not sure why.
Conundrum, but kind
of interesting.
So I'd like to introduce you to
a different kind of architect.
This is Cedric Price.
I've called him
the secret patron
saint of interaction designers.
He changed the way any
number of people in the UK
understood architecture
and buildings
and what they could do.
His life partner
was Eleanor Bron.
He died in 2003.
Eleanor Bron was in
the Beatles movies
and was responsible--
actually, she
was the inspiration for
the song "Eleanor Rigby."
So just a very
curious and very funny
person who liked to ask things
like, technology is the answer,
but what was the question?
And Cedric Price was
best known for things
that were never built. So
for instance, the Fun Palace
was designed in
the 1960s, and it
was supposed to be a
big cybernetic theater,
movable kind of place, where all
sorts of things could happen.
And the space was going to
learn from its users over time
and adapt to their
interests and needs.
And you could
change it over time
and use it kind of
as a big leisure
center to learn and
experience whatever
it is you might want to learn.
And he worked with a
25 member, 27 member
cybernetic community, which is
what you see here on the right.
And in this particular image,
it's kind of hard to read,
but it talks about input
of unmodified people
and then output of
modified people.
So they thought through
this like a system diagram.
He did this project
with Joan Littlewood,
who was a radical
theater director
and a protege of the German
playwright, Bertolt Brecht.
He also was really
inspired by Gordon Pask.
And Gordon Park is
a cyberneticist,
who also had a big influence
on a lot of architects.
And a piece that
he wrote in 1969
talked about changing
this design process
in some interesting ways.
And he suggested that we
"turn the design paradigm
in upon itself and
let us apply it
to the interaction between
the designer and the system
she designs, rather than the
intersection between the system
and the people who inhabit it."
So rather than the system you
designing doing your bidding,
maybe it does
something different.
Maybe it augments and creates
something different than what
the two people put together.
This is a drawing he gave
of second-order cybernetics.
He wrote things like,
"assume for the moment I'm
the successful businessman
with the bowler hat,
and I insist that I'm the sole
reality where everything else
appears only in my imagination.
I cannot deny that
in my imagination,
there will appear other
people, scientists,
other successful
businessmen, et cetera,
as for instance in
this very conference.
Since I find these apparitions
in many ways similar to myself,
I have to grant them the
privilege that they themselves
may insist that they
are the sole reality,
and everything else is a
condition of their imagination.
On the other hand, they cannot
deny that their fantasies will
be populated by people,
and one of them may be I,
with bowler hat and everything."
So this is second-order
cybernetics
where the fact that you're
engaging with the system,
changes the system.
And if you start looking
at the design process
as something that needs to
take that into consideration,
design begins to look
a little bit different.
Cedric Price was, again,
very, very inspired
by his interactions
and collaborations
with Gordon Pask.
One of the projects
that he designed
was something called Generator.
This was never built,
but it was a project
that was in existence
from '76 to '79.
And it was a set of 12 foot
cubes, 150 cubes, walkways,
boardwalks, that could be
moved around and recombined
for whatever purposes
someone might like.
This was an arts retreat
center for a wealthy patron
in Florida.
He always really
liked moving cranes,
so there's always a
moving crane here.
And Generator would
come together like this.
There was grit on the ground.
He put cubes over it, roofs
on top, connect the parts.
And then you could put up the
side baffles and the stairways
and do what you'd
like with the space.
You could also model it with
these little qubit parts
that you would see.
He thought that maybe
fun things might happen,
like you could take
a bleeper walk.
I will remind you, this is 1977
or so when this idea came up.
And there's something
strange about a mouse rolling
around a cube.
But it's strange and weird
and funny all the time.
And again, we look
at Gordon Pask.
Gordon Pask did a project
first in 1953 and then
in 1968 called--
which became The
Colloquy of Mobiles.
And what happens with
these mobiles are
you interact with it, and
it interacts back with you
until it gets bored.
And Paul Pangaro, who is a
cyberneticist and a professor
at the College for Creative
Studies in Detroit,
has just rebuilt The
Colloquy of Mobiles
for the 50th anniversary
of the original project.
He's Gordon Pask's archivist.
And it's up right now,
as we speak, in Detroit.
So what does this have
to do with Generator?
Well, Cedric Price
realized it was unlikely
that people were going to want
to move around Generator enough
and learn from it and do
the kind of funny things
that it would expect.
So he began to work with John
Frazier and Julia Frazier, who
were computer scientists
as well as architects,
and wanted to put together
a set of programs that
would be used by Generator.
So there would be
micro-controllers on all of its
parts, an inventory
program, a design program--
that's what you see here, you
can pick up and move these
cubes, and they
plot and print out--
and a boredom program.
And the boredom program
said the following.
In the event of the site not
being reorganized or changed
for some time, the
computer starts
generating unsolicited
plans and improvements.
And this is something that John
Frazier wrote in his letter
to Cedric Price,
introducing these programs,
"If you kick a system, the very
least you would expect it to do
is kick you back."
And then he said, "You
seemed to imply"--
this is a handwritten footnote
that you can see down here
in the letter--
"You seemed to
imply that we were
only useful if we
produced results
that you did not expect.
I think this leads
to some definition
of computer aids in general.
At least one thing
that you would
expect from any
half decent program
is that it should produce
at least one plan which
you did not expect."
So this is where something
like Gordon Pask's Colloquy
of Mobiles makes its way into
Cedric Price's architecture.
And these are ideas
that we pick up today
in some really lovely ways.
On the next slide, I'm
going to introduce a project
by the roboticist,
Madeline Gannon.
She just finished her
PhD at Carnegie Mellon
in architecture, and she did an
exhibition at The London Design
Museum with a robot, a robotic
arm that would play with its--
play with somebody in its
midst until it got bored
and went away.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
Everything comes
together and you're
in the space with a
robot and you just
have a very raw experience
with this animal-like machine
responding to your every move.
All the technical aspects
melt away into the background.
It's incredibly important to
have opportunities and spaces
to come in and experiment
and misuse these existing
technologies.
[END PLAYBACK]
She didn't know about
Gordon Pask or Cedric Price
when she did this project.
But I find it compelling
that many years later, this
is exactly what
she is trying to do
and trying to get us to
rethink, our relationship
with our machines.
She calls herself
the robot whisperer.
The third person I'd
like to talk about
is Nicholas Negroponte.
And you'll notice
here, he always
seems to have his
fingers in the picture.
He always seems to be
gesturing at something.
You would probably know him as
the founder of the MIT Media
Lab.
But before the Media
Lab, he ran something
called the Architecture
Machine Group at MIT.
And that's what I want
to talk about here.
The MIT Architecture
Machine Group
was in the School
of Architecture
but worked very
closely with the AI Lab
and developed interfaces,
programs, and environments
for artificial intelligence.
The gesture thing, he's the
author of a number of books.
The book that you'd probably
be most likely to know
would be called,
"Being Digital."
And "Being Digital"
came out in 1995.
But in 1970, he wrote a book
called "The Architecture
Machine," and he dedicated
it to the first machine that
can appreciate the gesture.
Nicholas Negroponte
is a clever man.
But this book, I
think, is actually
fascinating and
really important.
It was a theory of design
for artificial intelligence
that I think still
holds weight today.
I want to point out a little
bit about the funding structures
of the Architecture
Machine Group
and of artificial
intelligence in general.
The Architecture
Machine Group was
funded by the Information
Processing Technology
Office of DARPA and the
Office of Naval Research.
The Office of Naval
Research was so
important for
defining the funding
for artificial intelligence
from pretty much its inception
onward through the '80s.
So vital that I think that
Marvin Minsky has referred
to Marvin Denicoff,
who was the program
officer, as the grand old man
of artificial intelligence.
So the thing to point
out is something
that Paul Edwards,
the historian,
has referred to as
the closed world,
that artificial
intelligence was primarily
developed within Department
of Defense funded entities,
because it meant a
small group of people
could continue to
work on these projects
through the same social
network, friendship
networks, and
professional networks that
had been developed since
the end of World War II.
Where NSF funding, National
Science Foundation funding,
automatically, and by its very
spirit, tried to throw things
open to the world
and open things up
and bring more people in.
So it was desired by
DARPA, DARPA IPTO, and ONR
to keep funding and development
in these small networks
of people.
You could get
things done better.
And it meant that the
Architecture Machine Group
started to structure their
work like the AI Lab did at MIT
and work very closely on
interfaces and small machines
and environments for
artificial intelligence.
One of these first
projects was funded by IBM.
It was called Urban2
and then later, Urban5.
And it was a conversational
user interface for urban design.
This is 1970.
I actually started a
little bit before that.
And what happens here is a
user chooses a set of blocks.
You see these squares
down at the bottom.
And then there's a
conversation going
on at the side using
this light pen to select
questions and answers.
And it asks you
questions, and you
use the conversational
dialogue and the buttons
here to determine what the
attributes are of these areas
that you are designing.
So its for urban design.
And "The Architectural
Machine" book
outlines and critiques
their study here.
You might notice this last one
that says, Ted, many conflicts
are occurring.
And they said, it was charming,
but it printed garbage.
But at least it was
friendly garbage.
Those are the words
that they used.
And I think it points
out, if anyone here
has tried to design a
conversational user interface,
you know how easy it's
going to seem on the surface
and how hard it is in reality.
We could look back to someone
like Joseph Weizenbaum in 1966,
who created ELIZA,
the therapy program.
It's a question and answer
conversational user interface.
And it's very difficult
and problematic
in ways that caused Joseph
Weizenbaum to rethink
his own total engagement
with computation
and artificial intelligence.
So everybody knows that
this is difficult to do,
and yet, we continually
try to do it anyway.
Nicholas Negroponte
and Marvin Minsky
were friends throughout
their entire--
throughout Nicklaus'
entire professional life,
until Marvin's death
a couple of years ago.
And here you see a robotic
arm stacking blocks.
A lot of AI problems
were developed in what
were called MicroWorlds.
So you focus in on some
small part of a project--
some small issue.
You're looking at edge finding.
You're looking at
computer vision.
In fact, you're
still, today, thinking
about computer vision in some
very specific small ways.
I know Justin was just
taking a computer vision
class at Stanford.
And you tried to throw
away the rest of the noise
and just focus in
on that problem.
And that's appropriate
for some period of time.
But after a while, MicroWorlds
didn't actually scale up,
and this gets to be a problem.
But as I mentioned, the
Architecture Machine Group
worked in MicroWorlds as
well and AI interfaces,
and this is a project that they
did in 1970 for the Software
Show.
It was a museum show
at the Jewish Museum.
And information technology,
its new meaning for art.
And so here you see
all of these cubes.
Isn't it funny,
Generator has cubes,
and Urban5 has more cubes.
And you've got this
set of mirrored blocks,
400 mirrored blocks, a
five foot by eight foot
pen and a gerbil horde, a
gerbil colony living there.
And it's going to be
difficult to read this,
but it says, gerbils
match wits with computer
built environment.
And what SEEK did was stack
blocks, and what gerbils did
was move them around
and knock them over.
This is the gatefold of
the software catalog, Life
in a Computerized Environment.
And there's this great
quote from Ted Nelson who
says, "Our bodies are hardware.
Our behavior, software."
And it's Paul Pangaro who
made the contemporary Colloquy
of Mobiles.
And a member of the Architecture
Machine Group who told me,
it was a little bit
too true, because SEEK
tended to kill the gerbils.
In later days, the
Architecture Machine Group
turned to command and
control interfaces
that were explicitly--
that had explicit military
connections and applications.
And this is because the
only way, past 1974,
that you could get work and
artificial intelligence funded
was to align it with
command and control
questions and direct tactical
military applications.
This is due to some
legislative things
that had happened in the '70s
in the wake of the Vietnam War.
And so this is the
Aspen Movie Map.
It is kind of what
it looks like,
Google Street View that you
experience sitting in a room,
in a chair.
You zoom down the streets of
Aspen, Colorado in an Eames
lounge chair with joy
pads, and a video disk
produces the images for you.
They had a prototype video
disk player in the 1970s.
And the way you get
the images is everybody
goes to Aspen on vacation,
and you load up the Jeep,
and that's what you
have right here.
So you zoom down the streets,
and there other photos
that show what's in front of--
the two smaller screens
are usually maps
and are on touchscreens.
I want to point out that part
of the reason this project was
funded was that it was
in the wake of the jet
rescue, the hostage
rescue in Entebbe, Uganda.
An Israeli jet
had been hijacked,
and the rescue of the
hijacking was performed
by building a model desert--
or a model airport
in the Negev Desert
and practicing the rescue
under cover of darkness.
In fact, I think this is the
subject now of a movie that's
about to come out or is
coming out later this year.
And so the question
here became, what
would happen if you were able
to actually simulate and do
remote moving and move
down these streets?
So that would be the
stipulation for this project.
In later years, they were really
explicit about this in some
of the reports they wrote.
Minsky and his
colleague, Richard Bolt
wrote that, "We are
proposing to develop
human-computer
interfaces, on the one
hand as sophisticated in
conception as a cockpit,
and on the other hand as
operationally simple as a TV.
From either perspective,
the objective
is the same, supreme usability."
Later on, they started
delving into virtual reality
in certain ways and questions
of augmented reality.
So this provocation,
Mapping by Yourself,
is a postcard held up in
front of the Queen's palace
in Stockholm and
imagining what it
would be like to have a screen
that overlaid information
upon the world.
On the other side is
Westinghouse Window, basically,
a very early iPad like thing
that was still connected
to various technologies.
And you can kind of
see in the background,
there's a Selectric
typewriter and a Dictaphone.
But this was a mapping window
and intended to substitute
for maps in the battlefield.
It had 2 dimensional and
2 and 1/2 D capabilities,
depending on how
you would flip it.
And this is, apparently,
the first example
of a layered digital map.
I like the fact that Nicholas
Negroponte has always
understood what he
has been working on
and the conundrums and
contradictions about it.
And in his 1975 book, "Soft
Architecture Machines,"
he said, "I strongly believe
that it is very important
to play with these
ideas scientifically
and explore
applications of machine
learning that totter between
being unimaginably oppressive
and unbelievably exciting."
As I look at these
historical examples
and where we are today,
I find myself wondering
if we need new cliches.
Because when I do Google
Image Search and pop in AI,
this is what I get.
There's always this, the
wavy or the behold the hand.
And it's always that color blue.
It's like the blue
of the projector
when no one's in the room.
JSON lady.
No, this is jQuery, right?
Cyborg lady.
If these are views
of AI in the future,
I think we're in trouble.
But I appreciate some
of the subversive ways
that we can look at this
and some of the fun ways
that we can as well.
Is anyone here a fan of
Janelle Shane in AI weirdness?
I nerded out so hard at I/O this
year when I got to meet her.
She does very funny things
with AI that I'll talk about,
but I really appreciate that she
understands what she's doing.
And she said, "If life
plays by the rules,
image recognition works well.
But as soon as people or
sheep do something unexpected,
the algorithms show
their weaknesses."
So are these orange flowers
in a field or sheep?
Because she colored them
orange, it's not sure anymore.
Janelle's also done
things like, this
is 7,000 paint colors
fed to a neural net.
And it begins to create
new colors, all of which
are terrible, and color names.
Exactly, I've been
reduced to tears
multiple times, caring
tan, burble simp, turdly,
ronching blue, tondar.
She fed the names to--
the names of Guinea pigs for
the Portland Guinea pig rescue
and came up with some
names for Guinea pigs.
Here, we have Hangar
Dan and Princess Pow.
[LAUGHTER]
And my husband has said, I
think any kid could come up
with Princess Pow, but
it takes a neural net
to come up with Hangar Dan.
Only machine learning
can produce [INAUDIBLE]..
And again, when I think
about these kinds of things,
I also find myself thinking
about this, which is actually--
it apparently was not Marcel
Duchamp, who delivered this
to the art show in 1917,
this urinal, as his object,
but rather a woman whose
name I can't remember.
They've just surfaced
that it wasn't him.
But this was part
of Dadaism, where
the world was going to hell.
It was World War I, and things
were really, really dark.
And so what does art mean
when things are really dark?
It means that you've got
to turn to absurdity.
You've got to turn
it upside down,
and so art starts
to look different.
Or you look at someone like
Eugene Ionesco, who wrote
the play "Rhinoceros" in 1959.
It's an absurdest
play, and it's where
a group of people in a
French town bit by bit
turned into rhinoceroses.
And of course, he's talking
about totalitarianism.
Ionesco wrote a play
called, "The Bald Soprano,"
because he had started
to try to learn English.
He's French Romanian.
And in order to learn
English, he would type phrase
after phrase from
this English book,
John and Sally go to the
store and over and over.
And he began to question the
nature of these meanings.
It's almost like he became
his own algorithm in order
to learn this.
And he produced a
very funny play called
"The Bald Soprano" about it.
Or you could even
look at something
like Luis Bunuel, who did "Un
Chien Andalou" in the 1920s,
19-teens.
But in 1970, '71, something
like that, he did "The Discreet
Charm of the Bourgeoisie,"
which is about a group of people
trying to have dinner, and they
just keep getting thwarted.
And it's a somewhat
contemporary surrealist film.
But all of these things
are ways to-- when
the world is on its head,
you upend it in art.
And I want to
suggest that maybe we
should be doing the
same things more
frequently with our algorithms.
Can anyone name what this is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MOLLY WRIGHT
STEENSON: Thank you.
We're saying that.
It's exactly what it is.
And the uncanny valley
is an idea from 1970
from Masahiro Mori.
This is the idea that when
robots are too similar to us,
they freak us out, and
he describes the eeriness
that that produces.
But he says something
else in his piece
in the article he wrote in 1970,
which is that it's about how we
understand what makes us human.
"We should begin to
build an accurate
map of the uncanny valley, so
that through robotics research
we can understand
what makes us human."
Until recently,
Manuela Veloso was
the head of the Machine Learning
Program at Carnegie Mellon.
And I was at a conference
that she was speaking at,
and she was talking
about, machine learning
is successful when "it does
what you expect it to do."
And for Cedric Price,
we saw the goodness
of when something doesn't
do what you expect it to do.
But there are some
dark things, too.
The stories that came
out earlier this spring
about Palantir's
predictive policing
in New Orleans, and the fact
that that had not been known,
not even to most people in the
city of New Orleans or city
officials.
I like the work a
lot of Mimi Onuoha.
Some of you may know her work.
She does a project
called Missing Datasets.
And you can't parse
what you don't collect.
And so if you don't
have the data,
you can't begin to parse it.
She does this both as a tech
piece and a critical piece
and an art piece.
So here you see a lot of folders
full of missing datasets.
And of course, if you
go look through them,
they're all empty.
She keeps a GitHub
repository where
she has these missing datasets.
And this one, civilians
killed in encounters
with police or law
enforcement agencies,
is no longer a missing dataset.
It's been collected.
And so she'd like to
see more of those.
And case in point,
sometimes, there's
an activist angle to her
work, but there's also
work that happens
as a result. A group
of Asian actors on
Broadway contacted her
about the roles that
are available for Asians
on Broadway.
And that blue line
is the Asian roles
in the play "The King and I,"
and the other bright light blue
that you see are
Asian roles elsewhere
in the 2014, 2015 season.
Similarly, you can
see the problems
for black actors
or Hispanic actors,
just not a lot
available at that point.
But by collecting
this data, it became
possible to change the equation.
And now, there are more
Asian actors on Broadway.
This is not a matter
of an algorithm,
but it's just, quite
simply, a matter
of the collection of data
and collecting the data
and naming it, making changes.
Oprah.
But I'm struck by the things
that machines don't do,
that we don't have good machines
for picking raspberries.
And we kind of do for
picking strawberries,
but it's very, very
difficult to get this right,
to manipulate, to
do this properly.
And I'm struck by the
fact that if you--
I think it was in Sweden,
there was a mining operation
that had a truck, that had
some very nice machine learning
algorithms operating
it more efficiently.
And it was so efficient that
it dug itself into a rut
and couldn't get back out.
So they had to introduce
noise into the system
to allow for the vehicle
to not too expertly
dig itself into the ground.
So in closing, I'll say that
AI is new, but it's also old.
And that it is a
matter of architecture.
It's a matter of infrastructure.
And it's a matter
of how we design.
This is something I see in my
neighborhood in Pittsburgh.
I go running by
Carnegie Robotics.
I'm not totally sure
how I feel about it.
I'm still not sure
how I feel about it,
but I think it's
pretty compelling.
But this is the
thing that I need
to come back to over and
over again, which is our man,
Cedric Price.
He says, "Technology
is the answer.
But what was the question?
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name Avi Melina.
I'm an analyst here at Google.
And I've been getting
really interested
in some of the things happening
on the edge of this space,
like generative design
and some of the stuff
that Autodesk is working on.
And I'm curious as to how--
where you see this
space evolving fastest,
because like 3D printing,
there is usually
industries that
pick it up first.
Where do you see the
first mass market
case of architectural AI or
intelligence really happening?
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON: That's
a really good question,
and I'm not sure if I have
a well-thought-out answer.
But I'd point out that
the history of 3D printing
is already quite old.
And so what we see the uptake
in now at a consumer level
or at a professional level--
and the other thing is, I
don't think that 3D printers--
I think they became
something that--
it was said, they were going
to transform everything
in the world.
And so then everybody
started getting makerspaces.
I'm not sure that
that has actually--
printing objects has
made the world change.
But the question of
generative design,
I think that architecturally,
the primary focus
has been on form
and representation.
You use any number of
authoring programs and design
programs to produce
work that you
wouldn't be able to otherwise.
I get very curious, again, about
these old ideas that I still
think are vital about how
they change the design
process and the
ingredients that go
in that make us think
of something that
isn't necessarily just
ending up in form,
but ending up in how
we construe design.
Thanks.
It's a good question.
Now, I'm going to try and
figure out the answer.
AUDIENCE: So Rohit says, any
thoughts on Bill Mitchell's
role, "City of Bits" and/or
urban design on software
other than Sim City?
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON:
Bill Mitchell
was, at points, the Dean of the
School of Architecture at MIT.
He ran the Smart Cities Lab,
absolutely vital individual.
He's actually an alum
of my master's program,
and he died about
five years ago.
And I didn't write about
him very much in my book.
I was focusing on a
slightly earlier era.
But he's a totally vital figure.
And there's a woman named
Anne-Marie Brennan right now--
she's a graduate
of my PhD program--
in Melbourne,
Australia, who's been
working on some of his work
and using his archive there.
So I think we're going
to see some stuff
forthcoming about Bill Mitchell.
But you also see
his work in-- you
see how he's inspired people,
including Anthony Townsend, who
wrote the book, "Smart Cities."
And he's been thinking a
lot for the last 20 years
on urban planning, smart
cities, and development.
I guess from a smart
city perspective,
I keep going back
to two big concerns
that smart cities tend to be--
and again, I get to say this,
because I'm an academic,
I guess.
But it seems to be viewed as
the locus of really great,
big enterprise deployments, like
if we used to get excited about
enterprises-- the scale of
a building or a campus--
this is even yet
still more tech.
And a lot of it hasn't been
very graciously designed.
I also think of that
idea of MicroWorlds,
that the question of
scale is really vital.
But when we say scale, it means
a lot of different things,
like is it one to a billion?
Is it tiny to great big?
Is it-- has many more users?
Is it-- has many
more stakeholders?
And I think designers
and architects are really
well-positioned to talk
about issues of scale.
But it's the hardest
thing, I think,
for us to figure out what we
mean when we mean deploying
on that kind of scale.
Thank you, Rohit.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is Christine.
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON:
Hi, Christine.
AUDIENCE: I just wanted to
ask, what are you most excited
about that's getting
researched now
or an idea that you might
have just heard about?
What in this field are
you most excited about?
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON:
Thanks for that question.
That's a really nice
thing to be asked.
Well, I recently received
this named professorship,
and it's the K&L Gates Associate
Professorship in Ethics
and Computational Technologies.
I'm not an ethicist.
I'm a designer, and
I'm a historian.
And I'm really
curious about what
we talk about when we talk about
ethics, because I don't think
that it means ethics per se.
You can't just sprinkle
some ethics on top
and make the food salty,
and that doesn't work.
And it makes me remember that
time in the '90s and 2000s when
people discovered
usability and said,
we need some usability
on this website.
And I'm like, no, you
don't want usability.
You want it to work.
You want it to be good.
And I'm going to leave here and
go to Stanford to meet up with
Fred Turner, who if you
haven't read his recent pieces
in "Logic" and in
"032c," you should.
The "032c" piece
came out this week.
The piece in "Logic"
is a few months old.
So he's the head of the
communications department.
He's a historian of, among
other things, Silicon Valley.
And we're grappling with a
question about education,
and he's speaking about
engineering-- writing
about engineering education.
But I think anyone
who's going to work with
stuff, how do we educate people?
Engineers are increasingly,
Fred will argue,
STEM-oriented, and
then anything else
is relegated to
other departments.
But how do you make an
ethical approach not
be a blow off class?
How do you make it be a
part of the datasets that
you're-- the problem
sets you're working on?
Part of my interest in
casting the role of design
to work in different kind
of areas is because of that.
You can work with designers
on framing a problem,
determining what data
should be collected,
how it should be
used, how it should
be visualized or explained.
So I have questions about that.
I have questions about
the possibilities
and impossibilities
of explainable AI.
And honestly, if
you just sit me down
with a new history or
a bunch of documents
about the history of AI, you
won't see me for a while,
because I'll be very happy if I
can come back into that stuff.
But I think we have some
very human questions that
also meet the jobs of
the people in this room
and the people on my campus and
probably the places that we all
studied, that need broader
approaches than just the most
efficacious and
efficient approach.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So one more question
from the Dory, also from Rohit.
Why aren't there
more real architects
celebrated in the field
of software architecture,
other than
Christopher Alexander?
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON:
Bless you for asking this.
It's so great.
Thank you.
I asked Allen Cooper
a couple of years ago,
can you name another architect?
And I did this to
Kent Beck, too.
And just silence for--
and I think that Kent
Beck said, Le Corbusier.
And I think Allen Cooper said--
what was it-- John
Portman, the guy
who did the Embarcadero Center
and the Bonaventure in LA.
It would be better if
we had other architects.
But I think the other thing
is that Christopher Alexander,
as a mathematician, it's
something that everyone
in the room deals with.
You work on some very tiny part
of an absolutely huge problem.
How do you go back and forth?
How do you keep
that in your head?
And Christopher Alexander
can explain that
to people in a way
that really resonates
with them, the working
on these two scales,
and then explaining
why it actually matters
on a cosmological sense.
His late stuff is very woo-woo.
And that really
resonates, and it really
doesn't resonate with most
architects who build buildings.
So I'd like to see Cedric Price
get taken up by everyone else,
because he's fun.
Alexander's not much fun,
but Cedric's a blast.
And to get to know other
architects out there, I think,
that the classes of people over
about the last four or five
years to graduate from
architecture school or design
school or those of you
who are in the spaces
that crossover are really
doing interesting work
and interesting ways
of thinking about it.
If you want to look
at something fun,
look at my friend
Fred Sherman's work.
He's an architect.
He's a professor
at Oregon State.
And he has a book coming
out on space architecture,
like space exploration,
architectural histories
next year so fantastic stuff.
AUDIENCE: Through
your talk, I think
sometimes when you mention AI,
I would consider it as more
like human-computer interaction.
The reason I'm saying that
is because I'm an engineer.
So when I got my PhD
more than 10 years ago--
if you have a PhD
in AI, it's not
as easy to find a job as now.
So in my understanding, we have
a lot of breakthroughs in AI,
like core technology,
I'm talking about,
for example AlphaGo
or image recognition.
Or if you look at
IBM Watson, so when
they won the "Jeopardy"
show at that time.
So we're talking about, there
are different types of AI core
technology advancements,
and that's the reason
we bring back the trend of AI.
But this is quite different
from what you're talking about,
like the human-computer
interactions.
And I think IBM calls
it cognitive computing.
So would you agree
with me if I tried
to understand-- when
you say AI, it's
more like human-computer
interaction,
which is not the core
AI algorithm that we're
talking about.
MOLLY WRIGHT STEENSON:
So yes and no.
Thank you for that.
That's great.
And to be clear, the focus
of my research in this book
is 1960, to some
extent, 1948, because I
look at cybernetics a lot--
but to really about 1977, 1980.
The parts of the book that
are focused on later material
are not focused on
questions of AI.
And I agree with you that they
are questions of human-computer
interaction, but I would
say that when Negroponte was
writing this book-- he was
writing the book in 1970
and doing the work in 1970--
he was developing
interfaces with the AI Lab,
using their technologies
and their environments
and basically, tinkering and
working in that capacity.
So yes, they are-- it's
input and output devices
and all kinds of ways that the
lab over that period of time
played with that.
It becomes human-computer
interaction,
but I don't think HCI as a
field really comes together
in that term until the 1980s.
I'd need to look at my notes
to remember exactly when.
I will say that I'm very curious
about what happens in the HCI
community around
1990, because there
is some interesting
crossovers that I think have
things to do with HCI
and interaction design
in ways that are--
in things that are really vital.
And yeah, I would
also agree with you
that things are way
more complex today,
and I have skated by all of it.
So my understanding
of it is more nuanced.
But again, I'm a historian of
technology and architecture,
and I'm not someone
who got my PhD in AI.
But yet, when you start
looking at it today
and the implications and the
different kind of terms that
people are claiming-- cognitive
computing, deep learning--
there is a whole different
set of things to start
looking at and studying.
There are their histories.
They're going back to
the 1980s and 1970s,
that I haven't yet gotten into.
But you're right.
And yes, but no, but yes.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you for that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much,
everyone, for coming out today.
And thank you, Molly
for your presence here.
MOLLY WRIGHT
STEENSON: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]